We did a segment last week before Thanksgiving,
might have been the week before about how
Fox News has been so effective at radicalizing
their own viewers that Fox News viewers are
now turning on Fox because Fox isn't radical
enough.
And the context was election results.
As you saw, there are some Fox anchors, Chris
Wallace, Neil Cavuto, Eric Sean.
They acknowledge that Joe Biden won the election
and you saw furious Trump supporters abandoned
Fox, along with Trump himself promoting even
more radical and farcical news sources.
018 and Newsmax.
And our friend Molly Jong fast wrote a piece
about this in The Daily Beast.
It's worth checking out.
It's called Fox News is no longer insane enough
for Fox viewers.
And she writes, They built a huge outrage
machine.
Then some of them tried to be real news people
for five minutes and now the.
Rage Machine is outraged at them.
This is the irony, I think the phrase that
applies is if you fly too close to the sun,
you will get burned or something like that.
They created this.
They told their audience, you can't trust
the media when they say things that don't
sound right about right wingers.
And you've got to be outraged when you were
told those things.
And now their viewers are seeing Fox sometimes
report accurately that Joe Biden won.
And so they're furious with Fox and they don't
trust Fox and they're looking for something
else.
They were chanting.
Fox News sucks at various protests over the
election results in the days after the November
3rd election.
And Molly writes in this article, quote, But
the problem is that Fox had built an audience
that had gotten more and more radicalized
with each passing year by Fox's content.
So by election night, when Fox anchor suddenly
wanted to play things straight, it created
a phenomenon whereby Fox News was unable to
keep up with the conservative outrage generated
by Fox News.
And this is exactly right.
And part of it is that you still have on Fox
News itself people promoting and supporting
Trump's voter fraud theories.
This is part of the radicalization.
Fox's opinion.
People have radicalized their viewers against
anyone telling them Trump lost it.
Just so happens, there are also people on
Fox News telling them that Trump lost.
We looked at clips earlier from Maria Bartiromo
indistinguishable from a North Korean state
media anchor reporting news about Kim Jong
un.
And at the same time, we have Eric Shawn saying,
well, Biden won and there's no evidence of
the fraud Trump claims exist.
So this is where we start wondering about
the future of Fox.
You might see a fracturing of the agenda setters
in right wing media where Fox News sets the
agenda maybe for what we'd call more traditional
reactionary ideas.
And then the stuff of the last few weeks,
the Kuhnen stuff, the types protesting elections,
they may be fracture off to OCN or Newsmax.
It may all change after January 20th when
Joe Biden is elected.
It all remains to be seen.
But the important takeaway here is Fox itself
is to blame for this, at least in part.
They created a safe space for fact free, baseless
nonsense for years, which they attempted to
present as news.
This is the best that they have made and maybe
they will suffer financially from it.
I don't know.
But it will be very interesting to see what
the right wing media landscape looks in.
For example, six months, a few months into
Joe Biden's presidency.
Once vaccines have been rolled out for coronavirus,
where will the conspiracies lie?
What will Fox look like?
What will on and Newsmax look like?
We can only wait
and see.